[Applause]
[Music]
located in the Persian Gulf Qatar is a
country with an area of a little more
than ten thousand square kilometers just
to give you some idea of just how small
that is
it's nearly 40 times smaller than
California so when this country got its
independence from the UK in 1971 Qatar
was a far away hostile and very very
poor place as a matter of fact it was
one of the poorest territories of the
United Kingdom and well that kind of
made a lot of sense the Qatar Peninsula
is a place where temperatures can reach
50 degrees Celsius in summer it's almost
completely covered by desert and it was
certainly one of the most uninhabitable
places on earth but it didn't stay that
way forever and today Qatar is the
richest country on the planet that's
right the citizens of this tiny nation
enjoy a per capita income of more than
125,000 dollars which is almost three
times the income in France and five
times that found in Chile
[Music]
this is a country which was almost
uninhabited a country that could hardly
survive on its fishing industry and
today it looks something like Scrooge
McDuck safe people things need the
government of Qatar has investments and
properties all around the world it is
the birthplace of Al Jazeera the most
important Arabic media company and well
then there is Doha the capital which is
a sea of skyscrapers malls and luxurious
cars a mix of Monaco and Vegas but
without the alcohol and gambling there's
no room for simplicity everything is
sumptuous huge and sparkling in Doha on
how sauce tava conflict areas reporter
Qatar has gone from being a dark shelter
for what harvest preaches and has become
what people might consider the most open
country in the Middle East this is of
course excluding Dubai but as you might
know Dubai is an emirate and not
actually a country in modern-day Doha we
can find international universities or
the so-called church city a complex of
Protestant Orthodox and Catholic
churches like the Church of Our Lady
rosary
20 million dollar Catholic Church which
seats 2700 is located in the southern
outskirts of the city on land donated by
Sikh Hamad bin Khalifa al-thani Katara's
Amir so now the question of course has
to be how did Qatar achieve this
remarkable transformation well let's
take a look about the lmg blessing
liquefied natural gas in other videos
we've discussed the keys as to why some
countries are so rich but in Qatar's
case it is much simpler and it can be
summarized by two things oil and more
importantly natural gas may massive
massive amounts of natural gas yep that
really is pretty much it if you're
disappointed well just hold on a second
because it's actually quite an
interesting story the first oil fields
they were found in the 1940s by the
1960s exploitation was already
consolidated and things in the poor
country of Qatar changed but not really
that much the thing is that it wasn't
until the beginning of the 1970s that
shale found the biggest treasure of this
country and that would be the North
fields which is the largest gas field in
the world but at that time well natural
gas it just wasn't that profitable you
see at the time gas could only be
transported through gas pipes and Qatar
was far from places where this gas could
be used even shale
well they soon forgot about it but well
things they were really about to change
in 1996 the old Emir Hamad bin Khalifa
al-thani who abdicated in 2013 staged a
coup d'etat while his father was in
Switzerland this Emir reached power with
a clear idea and that was that the
future of Qatar was in gas they simply
had to exploit their huge gas fields man
so well he did just that the new and
they're decided to invest in an
undeveloped and rare technology this
technology it's liquefaction which is
the ability to carry natural gas in its
liquid form so that it could be
transported in large ships as if it was
oil in order to do this the gas needed
to cool down and be kept at a
temperature of minus 161 degrees Celsius
which is minus 258 degrees Fahrenheit
now this is some
that is pretty inconvenient to do
so while Qatar they decided to invest
enormous quantities of resources in
order to boost the development of this
technology so that it could be used on a
massive scale because of that investment
Qatar is now the world's largest
exporter of LNG with this technology
Qatar is able to export its enormous gas
supplies to the rest of the world in
fact last year three-quarters of Qatar's
gas went to Asian countries like China
India South Korea and Japan and well
there's more because the industrial
complex the qatar has developed is so
big so large-scale that the country has
managed to have the cheapest costs of
extraction and liquefaction in the
entire world
to illustrate this a methane tanker of
LNG is four times cheaper in Qatar than
it is in the United States and this to
viewer well that's the secret of this
small and wealthy country but this
unites this only a part of the equation
I mean not only does a country have to
exploit the resources they have but they
also need to use that money to generate
other money or they're going to end up
like Angola or Venezuela so it besides
this innovative process Qatar has some
other keys to their success
[Music]
katar power
since Hamad bin Khalifa al-thani reached
power in 1995 things they have changed
significantly in his 18 years leading
the country Qatar's population it's
multiplied by five while at the same
time it's become the richest country on
earth so the old mayor he's got plenty
of reasons to feel proud of himself but
let's move on from this because Qatar is
started to generate a lot of economic
resources and the question now is what
are they doing with this money whilst by
what it may look like they've actually
mostly invested it both nationally and
internationally Qatar they've created
the Qatar Investment Authority which is
a huge funds to invest money all around
the world it is known as Qatar's power
because they have in their hands more
than three hundred and thirty billion
dollars and when you consider that the
population of Qatar is less than 3
million people but of those 3 million
people only 300 thousand are Qatari
citizens well you can do the math this
fund it has made significant real-estate
investments all over the world
in London a big part of the City belongs
to Qatar including offices hotels
apartments and swell in the United
States Qatar was in 2016 the fourth
largest office investor in the country
in Manhattan alone that this fund has
invested five billion dollars in the
last two years spans they're not just
investing in real estate this funds also
has major shares in many multinationals
guitar plays for instance one of the
largest shareholders of companies like
Volkswagen Iberdrola Barclays Bank
Tiffany and Co shell or even the judge
Roth's nest the oil company of the
Russian government in the image I'm
about to show you you can see how much
foreign investment has increased as the
production of gas and oil has grown
and it's not just international
investment here they're also investing
lots of resources inside the country
tens of billions has been spent on
highways ports airports research centers
financial centers etc etc and so you
might be asking now well what's the goal
of all of this well that is to be able
to in the future replace the income they
get from oil and gas with income from
all of these investments but you know at
the moment when the gas business runs
out is still too far away to really be a
problem there are no analysts who can
say when demand for gas will wane for
oil there are people who see peak demand
in 2030 others in 2040 too
but for gas demand is constantly growing
this idea they have of investing rather
than spending the money from natural
resources might be one of the most
important differences between Qatar and
other countries who are also rich in
natural resources most of them they find
it too easy to spend the money today and
not think too much about the future
[Music]
Ward's effective independence when Hamas
bin Khalifa al-thani reached power he
also had another thing in mind
Qatar it had to gain international
influence you see for years Qatar was
controlled de-facto by Saudi Arabia and
the new Emir just couldn't forget about
Iraq's invasion of Kuwait if Qatar
wanted to survive they needed to claim
their identity and gain international
influence otherwise any conflict with
Radar could compromise the independence
of the country
besides well natural gas it could pay
the bills now
[Music]
so in 2003 when Saudi Arabia requested
that the US take American troops out of
their country guitar didn't hesitate to
offer itself as a destination for those
troops they didn't even blink when it
came to spending about a billion dollars
to build the military bases that were
needed sprawling base 20 miles southwest
of the Qatari capital of Doha is home to
some 11,000 US military personnel indeed
it could be said that Qatar has taken
out a very comprehensive insurance
policy and well then we have the
founding of al-jazeera this has the
objective of obtaining global influence
and well they succeeded and this is
something we actually covered in a
previous video that you should
definitely check out they also developed
a foreign policy driving towards
international influence the blockade
all this political strategy made both
the United Arab Emirates and Saudi
Arabia very angry and in June of 2017
they announced a blockade accusing Qatar
of supporting fundamentalist groups and
terrorists and when it comes to Saudi
Arabia we could definitely call this a
case of the pot calling the kettle black
now it is true that Qatar has some dark
secrets I mean it is an absolute
monarchy after all but the country is a
good ally for the West especially the
United States and it's also one of the
most open countries in the region the
truth is that the boycotts it had a
different target to cut down guitars
strategy of international influence and
to essentially put them back in their
place however the blockade well it's
been a total failure first radars
position is not that strong very few
countries have supported it
not even Kuwait or a man also Qatar has
developed a better relationships with
Turkey and even Iran Qatar has simply
proved that they are strong enough to
weather the storm and finally it's
really important that we do make
something clear there are plenty of gray
areas in Qatar labor conditions that are
more consistent with the ones of a poor
country the situation of women in the
country and the lack of a democracy
furthermore the system needs to prove
that it can work without the government
because unlike Dubai the lead has been
taken by public initiative not private
and this is one of the reasons why Dubai
is still above Qatar in pretty much all
aspects but hey I mean it wouldn't be
fair to not acknowledge what they're
doing right like they're saving capacity
their productive investment and their
openness and while that's our opinion
here a visual politic and now we would
love to know what you think who do you
think will win the battle of the
countries in the Persian Gulf Saudi
Arabia or maybe Qatar well let us know
your answer in the comments below as
well as in this survey and also don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday also don't forget to check out
our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that aren't on mine and as
always well thank you for watching
[Music]